زياره الرئيس الاوكراني الى اوكرانيا ربما
ستزيد من اهميه البولندا تحديدا ستزيد من
اهميه دور بولندا اقليميا ودوليا بحسب
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الصحيفه اعادت
التذكير بان رئيس الحكومه البولنديه
كان احد ثلاثه زعماء اوروبيين وصلوا الى
كياف بعد ثلاثه اسابيع من بدء الحرب وفي
الشهر التالي وصل الرئيس اندريدودا للقاء
نظيره
الاوكرانيدا التي تم استبعادها لسنوات من
قبل القوى الاوروبيه واداره باراك اوباما
باعتبارها معاديه للروس تشعر بحسب نيورك
تايمز بانها كانت محقه في تحذيرها مما
تطلق عليه وارسو الخطر الروسي وتحذيرها من
الاعتماد على روسيا بشكل كبير ومنذ بدء
الحرف في اوكرانيا بات الموقف البولندي
اقوى جزئيا بسبب اشتراكها مع اوكرانيا
بحدود طولها 531 كيلومترا وعبر هذه الحدود
ما يقترب من 90% من المساعدات العسكريه
والانسانيه المقدمه لاوكرانيا الدوره
الجديد لبولندا دفعها لطموح لان تصبح ايضا
قوه عسكريه اوروبيه مع سعي الحكومه
البولنديه الى مضاعفه حجم جيشها الدائم
وتطويره باحدث الاسلحه الغربيه وعلى ان
يكون لدى بولندا قوه بريه ستكون الاكبر في
القاره الاوروبيه بولندا قالت انها تخوض
حروبا على عده جبهات فهي من ناحيه ترسل
كميات كبيره من الاسلحه والذخيره الى
اوكرانيا كما انها اكثر من مليون و300 الف
لاجئ اوكراني لكن تطلعات بولندا للعب دور
اكبر في السياسه الخارجيه الاوروبيه تعرضت
للخطر بسبب الصراع الطويل مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي فمنذ عام 2021 عندما حجبت بروكسل
35 مليار يورو من المنح والقروض المستحقه
لبولندا ردا على فشل الحكومه البولنديه في
التراجعي عن اصلاح نظامها القضائي
[موسيقى]